The Joe Rogan experience,
that's not good for.
Well,
no,
it's terrible for you.
It's,
and what it is,
is it's a,
it's a game.
It's like the office is a game and
there's very specific rules where this,
when the game starts in the beginning of
the day,
there's a boss and suddenly this person
who's just like you has authority over
you and can control,
basically controls your life and the
food for your kids.
And so you have to speak in a certain
language dictated by the corporation.
It's this terrible fucking game that
people forget as a game and they begin
to think,
oh no,
this is the way you're supposed to act.
This is real life.
And that's when you get like that B of a
song.
Did you ever see that b of a song,
the Bank of America,
do you ever see that?
It's like somebody filmed this corporate
merger announcement of a merger between
B of a and a and another bank.
And it's a guy saying to you to choose
one,
uh,
this song that he wrote about Bank of
America.
And it is what it will make your
eyeballs roll back into your head with
such existential horror.
Seeing these brainwash drone who's
obviously spent like a week writing the
lyrics to the song and is passionately.
Oh my gosh,
Natalie,
I'm singing the lyrics to how Great Bank
of America is as a corporation.
I think we should be able to play this
on pile you as a believer.
I was a corporate video that was made by
Bank of America,
right?
That was sent out to his employees,
know it.
Somebody had a camera out during this
like moment where some kiss ass who know
how to play guitar.
And everybody in the audience is clearly
like,
they seem uncomfortable to me.
They're just like,
oh fuck.
You know what it reminds me of?
It reminds me of a cult.
It's a cult.
The feeling there is that of a people
who've gotten absorbed into a cult,
and that's the only way to put it.
It's like they believe crazy shit that
is only even known by a relatively small
group of people and it's their entire
lives banking the bank of America way,
the way that we do business.
He's singing about the way they do
business and it's kind of obscure
banking terms in the song.
Really,
really terrible.
That sounds fucking awesome.
This can be found on youtube under bank
of America.
Sings Youtube.
I just want to say before you press
play,
I'm looking forward to this almost as
much so I'm looking forward to the new
Conan
some guests who have been so impressed
with your results to date and they've
listened to the plans being described
today and continue to be excited about
what's going to be the card business
today and beyond,
and that is Jim Dubois,
who is the consumer market exec for the
Manhattan market.
What's all this nonsense?
Who is one of our banking center manager
is a long winded Fela song together for
you,
so sound together for you.
Oh,
we miss those guys names,
which is probably for the best.
We don't want to diss them.
Well,
this is.
We'll go full
screen.
Oh No.
Now that we're the same.
Sue.
Great companies come together.
Mbn.
Hey,
it's bigger
and one bank,
one con,
one name.
That's the only
one spirit.
We get the sheriff who eating salt too.
Yay.
By the way,
is also like a 40 year old bald guy that
doesn't look anything like hipness that
he's like Larry.
David's younger brother going to do the
whole thing.
Yes please.
The cowboys.
Cowboys,
all you know this.
See,
this is amazing and incredible,
Suzanne.
Yeah.
Or is Nascar more your speed?
Everybody's got it back.
Got Coffee.
The guy's got a good voice.
He's got a real good voice.
She doesn't have a soul.
This is the kind of songs that you say
when you don't have weed in your life
regularly.
Piss testing.
You see this guy gets pissed.
Tested on the regular.
This is what sobriety gets here.
I can't do that.
No,
I can't sing like that.
It's great in his church choir.
I bet he kills it in the church choir.
Do you think he wants to dig?
You already had it thinking it comes to
me.
I feel like I feel like I'm going to be
honest.
I feel like someone could fuck his wife,
so mainly I feel like there's an opening
there.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Probably have you looking into this.
He's got more of a btk killer,
btk killer throws on underwear.
It strangles boys
on women's underwear.
Whoever this guy is into the favor of
this guys,
I'm sorry.
With dyspnea and we don't mean it.
You really would like to do is we will
offer you a hug and some weed and you're
very pixelated on the video,
so we're just judging by pixilations
mostly.
Well,
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean I think you got.
Maybe I'm just an Asshole,
but adult.
We're totally assholes.
I don't feel empathy for that guy.
He's just a guy now.
The banker.
He's got a job at supporting his kids.
Listen,
satanist.
He's a member of the church,
of course,
of the Corporate Church of Lucifer.
He's singing idol.
Some devil idle.
Fuck him.
Ah,
people he's exploiting.
Just imagine working in a cubicle next
to that.
Cocksucker is writing a shitty song and
he's bringing you in and running it body
while he farts is comfort and you're
having a smell.
That guy's,
this guy's a missions.
He's a human slug.
I hate them.
I just know he torments.
All right.
I just know he torments underlings.
That's why I haven't.
No,
so yes,
I see.
I saw him as like a fatherly figure in
the office,
gives out a lot of hugs,
but always had a desire to be a singer
and then this is a,
this is what he put together and then a
few people have his office.
We're proud of them.
A bunch were very embarrassed.
It's very embarrassing and it's going to
be a lot of talking behind closed doors,
but there's a few girls,
like a few chubby secretaries to thought
he did.
Awesome.
Oh yeah.
I mean I,
I don't.
I'm sure that there is other brainwashed
drones.
Carl did such an excellent job.
I really felt our higher standards
coming through his songs.
He really represents the B of a higher
standard
moment where he starts singing one bank,
you know,
like coming together.
He's like,
when you realized that he really doing
this is really going full emotions about
a bank passion.
It's his life and his team.
Passionate about being on team building.
Yeah,
and they made a merger.
You didn't even know.
He gets kind of nasty later on in the
song.
Where he kinda does is another bank.
The one of the lyrics is what's in your
pocket?
It's not capital one.
That's a lyric dissing capital one.
Does capital one,
would you fuck capitol?
Fuck all of them,
right?
Yeah.
We need a system.
I don't have a pro.
I mean,
whatever.
With the coins,
Bro.
Big Sorta here.
Works Online,
right?
Yeah.